if you're like me then most of your
favorite anime are packed with action
adventures and in some places even a
pinch of humor but wait let me ask you
which of the anime fight scenes in 2023
do you like the most from one of the
best last stands in anime to a climactic
fight scene that would define an entire
Series in this video we're counting down
the top 20 anime fights of 2023 so far
first up on our list is hani's battle
with the rumbling titans in Attack on
Titan season 4 part
three this seed was a fitting end for
one of the bravest and smartest in the
series even though the Colossal Titans
were so massive that they made
battleships look like toys hanji didn't
feel any fear and was ready to confront
them her battle with the Colossal Titans
might be one of the saddest moments in
the series and not only that it helped
in her character development as before
she was a curious researcher and now
she's become a brave and dependable
leader despite losing her life and
failing to stop the rumbling she was
able to help others escape when she was
out of Thunder Spears she used her
swords up until her gear blew up the
animation the soundtrack and the
atmosphere of the moment made it all a
fight to remember and even before the
fight Levi gave her the best farewell
she was amazed the whole time and stuck
to her character dying in a blaze of
glory
[Music]
next on our list is an anime that has a
really really long title Anice versus
algard in the magical revolution of the
reincarnated Princess and The Genius
young lady now this one was a fight
between siblings who had different
beliefs and suffered abuse that made a
significant impact on their lives both
arnes and algard are exceptionally
talented Fighters but it was back and
forth and not one of them seems to have
the upper hand this fight was full of
dynamic action and strong emotions Al
gan's ice magic was beautiful to see and
arnest with her sword was as deadly as
an assassin she even managed to deal
First Blood I personally didn't expect
to see a battle like this in this kind
of anime I thought it was just another
slice of Life isaki the animation was on
par with fate and the way algard
accepted his death at the end was
completely unexpected even if both of
them lived the moment was so impactful
that we could help be immersed in
it moving on we have Kenji versus Teto
in Bongo stray
dogs this fight couldn't be even more
satisfying as two evenly matched
Fighters give their best to win even
though Kenji looks like a farmer who he
is he's actually really strong and
somewhat too innocent what's amazing is
that even when he was stabbed he was
able able to bend teto's sword this was
a battle of raw strength and even if he
was one of the more physically gifted in
the detective agency Kenji was losing it
but that was until he was awakened Kenji
turned into an even deadlier beast and
even teto's punches weren't enough to
knock him down anymore the animation
wasn't God level but it was good enough
that it helped make the fight scene
especially kenji's attack feel as if
there was some actual weight behind them
even if it was a brief fight it didn't
feel rushed and it still kept that
intense and exciting atmosphere in the
end though they became friends because
if a strong man meets another strong man
it equals
friendship blasting their way into
number 17 is the battle between gel and
shadik in Gundam the witch from Mercury
now the witch from Mercury is one of the
new new series that have come out from
the franchise and even when the whole
plot revolves around the two main
characters they give some of the side
characters some interesting moments the
best one being this G is a hardn spati
while shadik is from the influential
earthian family which operates under the
benit group they were bound to fight one
another because of their affiliations
and it was a good thing they did unlike
other fights in space where they just
point and shoot the fight choreography
between these two used the environment
to their advantage making it even more
realistic what which from Mercury does
that's better than other Gundam series
is the way it uses the lighting and the
effects in space it was just glorious to
see and even if it ended in a draw G
managed to decommission shadik and
another Mobile Suit user in a two versus
[Applause]
one you ever want to watch an anime
after watching a top 20 list like this
one and you suddenly find that it isn't
available in your country well it really
feels like you're flying a Gundam but
you can only fly and not shoot so why
did you even have one in the first place
I know that sounds crazy but that's what
streaming come companies like Netflix do
because you only get to watch shows that
are available in your country which is
only a fraction of their Content Library
if you don't use expressvpn our sponsors
expressvpn is like having access to
every feature your Gundam has including
that sick and awesome transformation
that makes it super strong you can
bypass those pesky restrictions and
finally get your hands on their entire
anime catalog I've personally been using
it to watch the new jiujitsu Kaizen
season on Netflix all you have to do is
open up expressvpn click on the India
server and boom you can now watch some
Gojo action on Netflix not only that
expressvpn does something a little bit
extra and protects your data by
encrypting your internet connection no
matter how good that hacker is and how
smart they may be they can't break
expressvpn's encryption in their entire
lifetime find out how you can get 3
months free by clicking the link in the
description below that's expressvpn.com
Vin tube now back to the video punching
its way into our list is Mash versus
Silvera from
mashall
now this wasn't a fight but more of a
one-sided Beatdown it was a battle
between muscle and magic and it's safe
to say that no matter how good you are
with spells if your enemy was trained by
syama then say good night Mash is a
Brute Force Warrior who relies on his
physical prowess and speed while silver
is a magic man who utilizes all kinds of
spells Silvera is scum he was
undoubtedly strong but just one punch
from mash and he was already backed into
a corner another punch and he was on his
knees Mash even asked him if he could
take a third hit and if it wasn't for
that monster he would been killed on the
spot Sila was utterly humiliated and
even if Mash's animation style looks
like it was straight up from Mob psycho
they still stylized it really well to be
fair silver had it com in how many
people do you know that can make a broom
fly just by running like crazy Harry
Potter short
[Music]
can't
next up on the list is the new triy gun
Stampede where we see Vash fight it out
with million knives a lot of people had
negative reviews on this one especially
since it was mainly animated using CGI
but they were proven wrong as the series
proved to be one hell of an amazing show
each fight scene was good but this one
stood out Above the Rest the way they
animated million knives attacks was on
another level it looked like Vash had no
chance of winning but he proved it wrong
by doing the unthinkable even just
vash's reload animation was something
else but we have to wait for season 2 to
finally get to the ending this anime
blew my expectations away because of how
fluid and dynamic they made the fight
scenes it might feel like a fever dream
but it's definitely worthy of this
list moving on we have one of the more
recent yet equally good fight scenes in
2023 Ken Bachi and gry's figh in Bleach
Thousand-Year blood War this fight was a
battle of the strongest with each
fighter having their unique abilities
gachi has his unbendable will and he can
slice through anything while gremy can
make anything he imagines into reality
gen vachi wasn't getting bothered by it
though because even when gremmy summoned
the might of America and blasted every
gun known to man towards Kenpachi he
still came out undefeated their battle
was nothing short of legendary and if it
wasn't Ken Bachi anyone else who stood
in gry's way would have been annihilated
Ken Bachi C space itself but no matter
how Wild gry's imagination was he was
still defeated because he failed to
comprehend kenpachi's true strength and
self-destructed to this day a lot of
fans still talk about this moment and
rightfully so because it made it to the
top of the best fights in
Bleach
next on our list is the Eminence in
Shadow Sid versus Iris and berrix this
was gender equality at its finest
because all of them went all out Sid
also known as Shadow was a menace to
society before and after he was
reincarnated the scene was badass and
the way Shadow casually made berri's
struggle made him look more dangerous
Iris was just titled at this point and
even with her overpowered weapon and
berri's help it looked like Shadow was
the only one that was having fun it was
a thrilling and blood boiling fight with
each side giving us one hell of a battle
the animation was stunning especially
when Iris attacked both berrix and Iris
were full of rage and the black white
and red colors as Iris launched her
final strike were unique and
eye-catching in the end though Shadow
just stepped on them and made sure they
understood their Gap in strength one I
am Atomic and the fight was over if you
love overly Twisted MC's Shadow might
well be your new
[Music]
favorite
unexpectedly arriving at number 12 is a
scene from boruto when moshiki fights
kavaki boruto might not be known for its
consistency but there are some moments
where you have to acknowledge that it
was actually good and this battle is one
of them after moshiki takes control of
boruto gaki steps in to protect Naruto
who's now severely nerfed along with the
others for some time gaki could stand up
against moshiki because of his karma
seal as well as his training with Naruto
but it doesn't last long they returned
the boruto series to its roots and gave
us a classic hand-to-hand fight at the
beginning the animation was also
surprisingly good and the choreography
was the one that carried the scene the
moment boruto's rasing Gan was about to
strike gaki was done well and it made
the biggest impact even though there
were still alien powers involved it was
refreshing to see that most of the
battle was fought in classic Shinobi
style boruto still has a lot of work on
but it might just make a comeback and
mangar does know what I
mean up next is baky vers is yujiro in
Baki now Baki did everything trained as
hard as he could and fought the
strongest being in the world just so he
could face his father yujiro hanma the
most powerful creature on earth the
reason why the fight scene between Baki
and yujiro is so awesome is because of
its viciousness and intensity their
blows were so strong that they shook the
ground underneath them it's also
impressively choreographed with the
movements blending smoothly into one
another this was the battle that defined
the entire series and even though Bary
was strong he was still being beaten by
yujiro both of them were exhilarated and
even as pickle intervened bky forced him
to sit down which was pretty badass this
battle showed us bary's progress and how
strong he's become it was so over the
top that it was far from realistic what
what the [__] but it was no doubt
enjoyable as the fight reached its
conclusion yujiro acknowledged Baki as
the strongest in the world which is no
doubt the best father and son moment in
[Music]
anime
next is a fight from the anime
adaptation of the game near ultimata the
fight between 2B and 9s versus Adam Adam
was on a rooll in trying to eliminate
the last resistance groups of humanity
but they were fighting back 2B and 9s
then arrived to fight him in his final
form which is one giant monster tub is
the waifu we all want strong and deadly
they're at a disadvantage and not only
did they have Adam to worry about they
also had these cannibal robots the
soundtrack definitely carried this
battle because it felt so awesome
watching it the animation when Tubi
sliced the building in Half was
completely unexpected you really have to
watch the series to figure out why
they're fighting a giant robot monster
and once you figure that out this is one
fight that you don't want to miss I mean
how often do you see them you can use a
space laser an
enemy the ending was sad emotional and
brutal as 9s forces 2B to end things one
once and for
all
you ripping their WS is the third season
of record of Ragnarok more specifically
the fight between Jack the Ripper and
Hercules this was the battle between
ultimate Evil and ultimate good there
definitely was some 3D and CGI animation
which was better than the PowerPoint
presentation we got back in season 1
this fight was just as impactful as the
others and what made this even better
was that they used the city of London as
a battlefield as all record of Ragnarok
fights go it was bloody and you wouldn't
really know who came out on top it
looked like Jack was going to be the one
who was going to lose but he did
something unexpected we all know how the
fight between them ended and it was
truly emotional the weird thing is that
everyone even humans were cheering for
Hercules because Jack was just creepy
but the way Jack tricked Hercules and
dealt the finishing blow was a sight to
see this was a fight full of twists and
turns and I couldn't have wished for
more
[Music]
now we're in the big leagues because we
have hell's Paradise the fight between
gabimaru and zuo Jin if you thought the
record of Ragnarok fight was brutal then
prepare for this one in their first
exchange Gabby Maru instantly broke
Zan's arm and neck and if it wasn't for
his regeneration the fight would have
already ended right there even if Gabi
Maru burned zuji into a crisp he just
turned into a guy and fought back this
was a true Display of Power for Gabby
Maru 2 seeing as we finally get to see
how he fares against the tensent even
when he was at a complete disadvantage
at the beginning gabimaru threw his
hands with zuin until he came out on top
this fight was full of visuals
especially when Gabby Maru activates his
aesthetic Blaze this fight definitely
stuck with me as I continued the
series
we have Torin versus snake in Vinland
Saga season 2 so we're back to some
Classics now no special abilities no
Ninjutsu and no monsters this fight was
all about instincts and pure close
combat fighting ability what made this
battle even more interesting was the
fact that there were no clear villain or
hero we all love snake and Torin equally
and it gave it more weight the animation
wasn't over the top but it was clean and
a precise fit for a fight like this one
not one of them seemed to get the upper
hand although we can argue that toin was
holding back it was so refreshing to see
Torin fight back again after the Farming
Simulator the fight scene didn't look
like it was staged as if it was in a
Hollywood action film it was rough and
it made me feel as if I was watching it
in real life both of them wanted to win
the only difference was snake was
willing to
[Music]
kill
now this is an entry that you never
expected to see in terms of Animation
quality and dynamic choreography this
one easily Takes the Cake fog Hill of
five elements is known for how good its
fight scenes are with each one easily
being included in any list that involves
hand-to-hand combat but what made this
exact one Stand Out is the sound design
and the extremeness of the battle it was
fast-paced heavy-hitting and very flashy
the way they use different abilities to
attack each each other also needs a lot
of recognition shanu proved to be a
beast and even Schwan and Xing had to
fight together to bring him down this is
what fighter scene should look like and
if the plot was solid it might easily
become the top anime of the
[Music]
year blessing us next is another Chinese
anime that's so good I can't believe
it's underrated it's blade of the
Guardians Dalma versus the double-headed
snake versus Chang gurin it seems like
Chinese anime is showing Japanese anime
how to properly animate a fight scene
and in terms of Sword fights this one's
topnotch it started off with DAR and the
double-headed snake taking care of Chang
and gan's men but it quickly turned into
a three-way battle that was thrilling to
watch I can't believe how good the way
the camera followed their movements was
you still have to get used to the
dialogue but once you past that you get
an awesome fight you could truly see
that they're not holding back in the end
dalar was the one that survived and even
then the way he ended Chang guran was
brutal and
[Music]
satisfying moving up we have Black
Clover sword of the wizard King ASA
versus Conrad now this movie was full of
impressive visuals and great fights
between the different magic Knights of
the Clover Kingdom and the previous
wizard Kings who reincarnated some might
argue that the Mario Leona versus priner
battle was the best but in terms of
impact and grit the ASA versus Conrad
one does take the top spot Conrad is
undoubtedly one of the strongest wizard
Kings because of his key magic but any
magic is a disadvantage against ASA the
rainbow CED Conrad versus the black and
red arar was just a feast for our eyes
it l like Black Clover took demon
slayer's budget and made up for its
inconsistent animation in the previous
Seasons even when it looked like he
could lose Conrad gave it his all while
ASA unlocked a new power using his new
overpowered sword this battle blew my
mind away because when do we get to see
ASA fighting in
[Music]
space
blitzing its way into the top three is
the fight between muichiro the m hashida
and gyoko the upper Moon 5 in Demon
Slayer 3 Demon Slayer just keeps serving
us one Godly animated fight after
another from rengoku versus araza to
Tangen versus Garo and now muo versus
gyoko and I wish they would give us even
more just like the rest the animation
here is one of the best in the history
of anime in this battle it seemed like
muo was just about to be defeated when
guoko used the high IQ move and trapped
him in a water prison but when he
awakened his Demon Slayer Mark the
entire confrontation turned upside down
Migo's Mist attacks were a sight to
behold and the way he decapitated yoko's
head and sliced his body into thousands
of pieces goes to show just how powerful
a Demon Slayer can be when the Mark is
awakened it was clean it was impactful
and it was merciless this was a badass
scene that was made better by the fluid
movements of the
animation
up next is a fight that recently broke
the internet choso versus Yuji in
Jujitsu Ka when it comes to fights you
already know Yuji always puts on a show
from the first time we saw him throw
hands with mahito to his sick battle
against Hanami with Toto there's no
doubt Yugi's become a fan favorite for
others and he didn't disappoint in this
one too maa's new animation style looks
insane and the choreography in this
first fight was amazing choso and Yuji
use the environment to their advantage
which makes their constant back and
forth look more Dynamic like the moment
when Yuji used water to encounter Choo's
curse technique the animation and
lightning was Godly especially how fluid
Choo's blood attacks were this
one-on-one also gave Yuji his iconic
scar after choso gets a hit on him at
the end however choso won by giving Yuji
a solid Counterattack but the fun didn't
stop there because with Choo's
flashbacks comes even more surprises
Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen is the embodiment of a
perfect anime
[Music]
adaptation
and finally the fight that lasted four
rounds and more than a year we have
Luffy versus kaido in one piece even if
it was long and it took Luffy several
tries to beat him their last round was
one of the greatest Milestones of the
franchise as we finally got to see gear
five in action if you compile their
entire fight with all four rounds it
would last more than an hour which goes
to show how much buildup this one scene
had it broke the internet and everyone's
expectations as it was ridiculous and
also awesome at the same time you could
even see the various stars of the
different animators that worked on this
battle there was that sketchy one at the
beginning the Looney Tune style in the
middle and the classic one piece
animation when Luffy used his gugu no
badran gun to defeat kaido once and for
all it was a massive attack that was
just as big as only gashima itself this
fight had everything in it impact
animation emotions relevance to the plot
and even some humor it's without any
argument a 10 out of 10 for everyone if
odar wasn't just a genius maybe one
piece could have ended here that's
definitely not the case this fight is
only an introduction to the end and Oda
definitely has more in store for
us and that ends our list for the top 20
anime fights in 2023 2023 was full of
amazing battles but these ones are the
best of the best what anime would you
have added let us know in the comments
below and maybe we might just include
them in our next video don't forget to
hit that subscribe button and ring the
notification Bell for more anime content
See you in the next one